pologne hongrie font front commun en
ligne de mire les négociations
budgétaires en cours à bruxelles le
premier ministre mateusz moravie yates
qui doit rencontrer le premier ministre
viktor orban à budapest jeudi l'ordre du
jour de la réunion devrait inclure le
cadre financier pluriannuel
car la pologne et la hongrie ont
l'intention de coordonner leur position
de négociation sur le budget européen
approuvés en juillet dernier le budget
de l'ue et le plan de relance ont été
bloqués par les vétos de la pologne et
la hongrie le 16 novembre dernier
mercredi
ursula von der leyen a aussi le ton face
à la position de ces deux pays
les vétos de la hongrie et de la pologne
sont simplement irresponsable si cette
proposition n'est pas conforme au traité
de lisbonne comme le prétend le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban allons
devant la cour de justice européenne
c'est là que de tels différends sont
arbitrés pour budapest et varsovie
la forme actuelle du projet lit les
décisions budgétaires au respect de
l'état de droit
selon le porte parole du gouvernement
hongrois je cite c'est contraire aux
conclusions du sommet de juillet
souvent mise en cause par bruxelles en
raison de réformes considérées comme
anti démocratique
la pologne et la hongrie redoutent que
leur politique intérieure n'interfère
avec les dotations européenne qu'elle
espère le premier ministre polonais
avait quant à lui défendu l'utilisation
du droit de veto par son pays la semaine
dernière
si nos partenaires ne comprennent pas
que nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec un
traitement inéquitable des états membres
avec un bâton qui va être toujours
utilisé contre nous seulement parce que
notre gouvernement ne plaît pas à
certains
alors en effet nous tolérons pas
utiliser ce veto dans le texte il est
écrit que des sanctions économiques
peuvent intervenir après une atteinte de
l'état de droit
remettant en cause l'indépendance de la
justice ainsi que le respect des droits
fondamentaux
soutenu par la slovénie les
gouvernements polonais hongrois ne
semble pas prêt à plier sous la pression
de l'union européenne en pleine deuxième
vague de kovy 19
les vingt-sept vont devoir attendre pour
accéder au plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros et sur mon terrain si
la crise économique actuelle